[Music]
at the end of the first season of
Monarch the legacy of monsters we get a
chilling and terrifying scene of Kong
emerging from behind the jungle Hills of
Skull Island now what does this entail
what does this mean for Kong and Skull
Island and his SP in the merse timeline
will he be the main focus for the second
season and what is the role of Apex
cybernetics what are they playing in the
series are they creating a mechanical
giant as was stated in the end credits
of kotm well here in this video we will
try to answer all of these questions as
much as we can so let's get to it let's
begin with when does this exactly happen
so the series started in 2015 in the
modern timeline and with flashbacks to
the 1950s and 60s and then 1982 after
leaw ventured into the access money
andai he managed to come back up after
20 days there but due to a differential
SpaceTime displacement and Continuum the
surface world had already fast forwarded
20 years into the future meaning that
spending one day in the axis mundai that
under space equal to one year on the
surface so when Lee Shaw Kate and may
were dragged there in 2015 they were
trapped for 2 days and only managed to
come back up using The Hourglass
equipment from 1962 and with the help of
Godzilla killing the Iron Dragon
therefore by the time they reached the
surface in Skull Island they were promly
received by their friends and Apex in
2017 meaning 2 years had passed since
their departure in Kazakhstan and this
is where we were left at at the end of
the first season and then with Kong
emerging from behind the trees roaring
at the Apex facility now let's take a
look at Kong's design and size as seen
in the series well he obviously is the
same one and only Kong from the franch
Frise he has the same looks and body
design interestingly enough he had
already grown his beard and had become
an adult by this time so when we first
saw the monsterverse gong
chronologically that is in the universe
in this universe it was in 1973 and he
was4 ft tall back then he was still a
juvenile by the time Godzilla versus
Kong he had grown to 337 ft or 102 M so
backtracking a little bit during the
events of Kingdom Kong when Kamas
appeared on the island Kong was to be
270 ft in height or 82 M and this was
said to have occurred in 2021 which
means 4 years after the Monarch series
incident therefore Kong here in the last
episode of Monarch would have been a bit
shorter which is why he seems to be just
over the tree line in this series
therefore putting him at a height of
around 250 ft or 76 M and that is our
estimate and yeah most of the trees in
Skull Island are around 60 to 70 M or
maybe 50 m therefore putting our
estimate
correctly so let's take a look at the
storm over Skull Island is it the same
one caused by chots you know the
Perpetual storm that was scast over the
island and destroyed the ecosystem
leading to Monarch building a d facility
to house the surviving Skull Island
species and also Kong fortunately no not
yet that particular storm was created by
Monster Zero during the events of kotm
in
2019 and the remnants of it stayed
active for over 2 years and it was
attracted by CES us to the island in
2021 2 years later after kotm so since
the events of Monarch the legacy of
monsters ended in
2017 it will be another 2 years before
gidora and the Titans would awaken thus
this storm here would just only be a
regular tropical storm that occurs every
now and then on that island but it is
interesting that Apex cybernetics has a
facility there already has one there and
this place was supposed to be under the
sole jurisdiction of only
monarch anyway is the story going to
shift now to a most Skull Island Centric
story in season 2 and will K play a more
active role in it well the ending seems
to say that remember that if season 2 is
made then the timeline would most
probably start in 2017 itself then go on
to the remaining years before king of
the monsters kind of a way to cover up
the time between Godzilla 2014 and kotm
in all these years Kong reigned Supreme
in the island in Skull Island and there
were no the Titan that had been reported
on the island for during those years
that tried to challenge his Supremacy
the L was the Kraken back in the ' 80s
and before that was the skull devil in
1973 the next notable incident that we
know of that happens on the island would
be during kotm itself when the skull
crawlers answered gora's call to hunt G
on the other hand ignored it being an
alpha refused to call and Massac the
skull crawlers that emerged out of their
Subterranean habitat then the next big
thing would be the events of Kingdom
Kong with Kong defeating kots and a
Perpetual storm covering the island and
finally the Dome being built on that
island so anyway what is the role of
Apex cybernetics in this series well it
was a pleasant surprise that they
included The elusive Corporation into
the story line with May being a focal
point between them the characters of the
story and the organization Apex was said
to have been created by Walter Simmons
sometime after the events of the mut
battle in San Francisco and their
ultimate work was of course you know
Mecha Godzilla in GVK Godzilla versus
Kong within these years before that they
have Diversified their work into a lot
of stuff including the trials for
exploration of the hollow Earth this one
culminated in the H eav transports that
Gia and the others utilized to follow
Kong into that place into the hollow
Earth so it's obvious that Apex would
have had quite a few years of time to
reach research and develop such Vehicles
as well as pour tons of resources and
work into the creation of many other
facilities of theirs around the world as
well as the creation of Mecca Godzilla
this means that they should have had
soundwork knowledge about the Titans and
their domain Hollow Earth and therefore
this is where the loose ends are being
tied with them being in Skull Island and
actually seen doing the basic groundwork
for their later Feats of Titan
Engineering okay one other thing if you
you're a Die Hard monsterverse fan you
would know that in one of the unedit
scenes of Godzilla king of the monsters
one such new snippet States that monar
had been trying to recreate organic
Titans on the island you know for quite
a while before kotm and they have also
tried making a mechanized Giant on the
island before the events of kotm well
what if this is where we pick up on in
season 2 of monar the legacy of monsters
with Apex instead of Monarch using the
source code of May to develop a world
working neural interface and thus
creating a mechanical Kong to combat the
giant ape there on the island this would
again be research and development into
later creating the bigger Mecha Godzilla
and it would explain why Kong instantly
knew that Mecha Godzilla was the real
bad guy in GVK and ended up helping
Godzilla in the fight with him having
faced an earlier Mecca you know
theoretically in Skull Island before
kotm if this ever happens you know this
would tie up many Loose Ends
and lastly it is interesting to note
that the prologue of the series started
with Bill Randa on Skull Island being
chased by the mother long legs and then
ended up with the remaining randers
running away from Kong on Skull Island
itself you know it seems a bit
interesting right back to square one
anyway now we have come to the end of
the video If you like this one that
check this other one as well and do
check out our channel for other monster
ver content we might just have things
that you haven't seen before like
subscribe and we'll see you in the next
video take care fam